can you give me some light with happen
all right we got some Pommery champagne
here and Amsterdam we're leaving it
because we can't take it with customs
some people just got to find him
somebody's just gonna get some free
champagne tonight those bubbles though
[Music]
fake titles thank you so much
flick-flick thank you of the wine tweet
a havoc wine either online or like New
York so here we are it's a 422 p.m. in
Amsterdam on the way to the conference
super excited about this also getting
some text from my and Harper I haven't
seen a long time someone try to connect
with him guy who I met when he was a
Threadless steamer Threadless the
t-shirts a best dude ever I've got a
quick phone call right now with my Ruby
Tuesday's client and then the keynote
the Q&A and then I get to depart and I
got a phone call with a potential
Boehner sports client and for the last
four hours I've been laying in the hotel
just doing a ton of vaynermedia calls
operations operations operations I'm
sure babban 'he's got some b-roll let's
show it because i want them to see them
the boredom of the operations
sure hi sorry I'm s thank you know what
bro no I'll bring you back home thank
you
can somebody tell me who's in the
audience so I can get a little bit of a
sense it's Elijah how are you good
Richard
good to meet you man all the way yeah no
worries thrilled to be here the other
theme is a cross-cutting around our tech
round technology you know that this is
the world's moving fast right and it's
not just see what can you manage an
AdWords campaign it's tough it's
artificial intelligence and there's a
theme a little bit which are interest
which is just a union a partner with
someone does the world's moving way too
fast
accessible hotel every YouTube it's the
calm before the storm hey Brandon why
Margaret hold on one second YouTube it's
the calm before the storm I'm about to
go out here in Amsterdam and destroy
their faces sorry I'm ready
how's it going today hello
first of all this is this is beautiful
I'm thrilled to be in this amazing city
um what I'm really really happy to be in
front of you and I gave a lot of thought
backstage and on the flight out here
last night on what I wanted to address
and was interesting for me to think
about the theme that really drove me
during that thought process which is
ironically a pretty interesting word
which is practicality right instead of
like huh
instead of hyperbole in either direction
like this is the everything's changed or
the other way
none of it [ __ ] matters the kind of
cross-section of the two like how do you
sell a hotel room today yeah I agree
with you last ten minutes is good right
bring this over here cuz I've got a
theme there's always that moment when
there's finally a little bit of trust
once they realize that this agency is
really a proxy for me to do something
else that I'm not just trying to get
their scope once I get comfortable once
we get comfortable every one of them
starts to talk about all the things that
they're doing that they don't believe in
I'm going to leave you with this because
I've been watching a lot of head nods in
this room it is far more fun to die on
your sword than to die on someone else's
I'm inspired YouTube we're gonna make
this the episode thing you'll get
whatever you want Tyler but this is the
[ __ ] core of it you just saw it on
stage that's just you just saw it on
stage dying on your sword is better than
dying on someone else's so many of you
are doing things making decisions and
navigating your lives based on somebody
else's thesis you're doing it because
you think it's the right thing because
your dad's telling you it's the right
thing you're doing what you're doing
right now cuz you're pandering to your
boss even though you don't believe in it
this is how it's gonna play out you are
doing things right now yesterday you
made a decision that you don't believe
in but you're smart you did it because
you know how your company's scores
here's the problem with disruption and
innovation right now you're being
rewarded for being a yes person and in
36 months you're gonna be fired for
being a yes person and you're doing it
because you just need the security of
your job I'm telling you right the [ __ ]
now
if you're watching this vlog and you've
got like that means you have a certain
DNA please I implore you please die on
your sword not somebody else's if you're
gonna lose it's much more fun to lose
based on what you thought do you know I
mean do you know how many of you are
gonna lose on somebody else's thesis
it's gonna kill at you it's gonna eat at
you it's going to be the worst [ __ ]
feeling so please [ __ ] pause this
video right now and ask yourself am i
doing my [ __ ] because of me
then you're good whether you're winning
or losing or am i doing it because
somebody else is telling me it's the
right way or I'm subconsciously
pandering to please somebody or
something because I need the short-term
stability figured out the [ __ ] out you
know it and I know it you just need to
do something about it thank you
hey guys youtube listen this i put out a
post about you know stop blaming other
people stop right start blaming yourself
leave in the comments right now it's
super fascinating of course
you you know so my whole thing is like
blame myself for everything of course
there's other things that people are
doing right like if somebody runs me
over with a car right now and they were
drunk is that my father is their fault I
get that you can blame that other person
I'm not so much worried about the
actuality of the event we're talking
about the [ __ ] mindset Tyler when are
people immersed and it's the mindset the
mindset of blaming yourself allows you
to do so much more so when it's in out
of ten times on you you're moving
forward instead of looking backwards
sure the two out of ten but if you just
have that mindset it's just winner
mindset isn't a mindset everybody's
taking every word I say so practical yes
I understand that there's issues in the
world like it wasn't your fault that an
earthquake like drill your house I get
it it's the mindset to me I'd be like
man I shouldn't live in [ __ ]
California I mean I don't know like
mindset it helps you eat out of ten
times and the other two times you just
[ __ ] deal with it rant over what I
wanted to do with this session is mainly
do QA as broad or as detail as you like
to go I always find it funny luckily for
me the world keeps changing and the
platforms keep changing but the six or
seven things I believe in pretty much
stay the same so in environments like
this given that's a smaller group I'd
like to take the advantage and I think
yeah I think you should be selfish and
go very narrow because I still think 30
40 50 60 percent will share in that and
I think we have enough time here to get
to a lot of stuff so I'd like to open it
up into Q&A with anything that I
referred to or anything that you may
have in your mind that's overall digital
the only time I've been really booed was
at South by Southwest 2010 I think when
one of my opening lines was Jeff Bezos
is much better than Steve Jobs and I got
booed because I was such a fan of the
way he was navigating and obviously he's
grown in so much stature over the last
couple years Alexa
not only is gonna be booking you know
hotel rooms Alexa has the potential to
kill Google
guys one in every four searches on
Google is done by voice wanting to be
full excuse me one of their before
searches on Google in a mobile device is
done by voice notice how even the way I
said it I don't even believe in a
desktop world anymore yeah you're damn
right I mean think about this back to
what you were talking about earlier
family let's play it out families having
dinner right
talking about where are we gonna go
where we gonna go this summer right blah
blah blah
Alexa what's the front the friction is
zero now Google home might win
Google's biggest concern in the world is
Amazon because the next search engine is
voice and Alexa's ahead you give me some
alignment all right we got some Pommery
champagne here and Amsterdam we're
leaving it because we can't take it with
customs some people just got to find him
somebody's just gonna get some free
champagne tonight those bubbles the
it was up YouTube sitting here with
Gavin I still think better and D rock
and Jordan
I still think better than Mike the 2.0
is anyways sitting here in a restaurant
in Amsterdam you know it's interesting I
don't get a lot of downtime on my trips
ever this is actually weird this 20
minutes sitting here and having a beer
or a protein shake
Jordan's around and I'm enjoying it I'm
gonna start trying to hack my culture
and my culture hack my life and try to
get these 20 minutes on these trips you
know I go to Amsterdam and Turkey and
Hong Kong and I never really go there so
just even 20 minutes of hacking so
making commitment to the YouTube
audience 20 minutes of hack you know
it's always like either work all the way
through and travel or do a meet-up
which means I'm working even at a higher
level and even though I wanted your
meetups and things that nature in every
market that I'm in just having 20
minutes to get a little deeper with my
homies feel a little work enjoy meet
some of the cool peeps that are you know
around here these Amsterdam ian's is
cool so I'm gonna do that always get
better always those bubbles the